okay I have a couple sort of like uh
keeping them honest type stories for you
today we have been covering these scams
grifts and crony con jobs that have been
many of the contracts given out during
the Trump Administration and that
includes the PPE company that was only
around for two months with no employees
that was given a massive contract to be
basically a middleman for PPE back in
2020 earlier this week we talked about
API jacked the company given a 1.3
billion dollar combination of contracts
and Loan loans to make vaccine syringes
were about 200 million doses in they
haven't even built the factory they've
got not a single vaccine syringe out
there and this next story is actually
about some of these so-called deals that
Donald Trump made back in 2016 and 2017
and even before being inaugurated in
2016 he announced one or two and then
made some in 2017. you might remember
that Donald Trump once bragged
about a supposed 10 billion dollar deal
and Factory in Wisconsin
that he I guess convinced the company
Foxconn to make he once referred to this
deal as the quote Eighth Wonder of the
of the world and there was really big
Fanfare about it at the White House in
July of 2017 Trump saying it's 10
billion dollars it's 13 000 jobs it's an
incredible example of how I'm doing my
America first thing of manufacturing
coming back to the United States and it
was all going to be incredible it would
be a factory for Cutting Edge flat panel
televisions and monitors and it would
make Wisconsin a destination for Tech
firms and it was all going to be just
great
but some of us were suspicious for a
couple of different reasons number one
Foxconn is a Sly company with a very
charismatic founder and then chairman
Terry goo who is very PR thirsty and a
lot of it seemed like it was mostly
about public relations and we were also
skeptical of these deals that are really
just hey take some money and do me a
favor rather than economic policy and
indeed there were reports that even
Executives at Foxconn at the time were
skeptical that this was ever going to
happen not the least of which was
because the suppliers for the LCD panels
they were supposedly going to make
we're nowhere near Wisconsin and it made
very little sense to actually
manufacture those there case in point
the project never started as described
and now Foxconn is announcing you know
four years later now we're going to
scale back what that project is going to
be and instead of 10 billion dollars
Foxconn has announced it will be 672
million not nothing but that's a 93
reduction in the dollar value of the
project Trump also bragged it would
bring 13 000 jobs to Wisconsin Foxconn
now says well it's not going to be 13
000. it's going to be
1454. which is an 89 reduction in the
number of jobs that were promised and
that Donald Trump uh Trump announced so
should this surprise us no
but there's another aspect to this I
said at the time when Donald Trump and
Mike Pence were doing their Victory
tours announcing oh Foxconn is coming to
Wisconsin and Carrier Air Conditioner is
staying in I think it was Indiana
I pointed out at the time even if true
and of course with many of these deals
as we're now seeing it wasn't true but
even if true those deals were not
economic policy they were not scalable
they were Trump giving specific
companies a bunch of cash often in the
form of tax breaks or loans that
sometimes don't even need to be repaid
to do a specific thing that might not
even be dictated by the market like for
example Foxconn making LCD panels in a
place that's really far from where they
get all of their parts and at the time
the Foxconn deal was denounced by many
in Wisconsin who were rightly saying
this is a tax giveaway to a foreign
company they're getting uh they're
getting tax breaks they're getting water
rights they're getting the gr uh uh
green light to acquire and demolish
houses via eminent domain to build their
Factory it's not Economic Policy you
can't scale this it's just a handout
Trump bought the deal with our tax money
and that's exactly what this is becoming
now Foxconn did start buying houses to
demolish for their Factory uh they are
going to do it eventually but it will be
90 percent smaller than was promised and
in fact they're not even going to be
building a factory
for the flat panel displays that detail
has also changed they're going to be
making server components and
Communications technology products and
maybe medical devices which is fine but
every detail fell apart from the
original deal and it will be 10 of what
it was promised to be
five six years later who even knows when
so the project is another microcosm of
the Trump presidency in some total and
and it wasn't just Trump taking his
victory lapse with this project then
Republican governor Scott Walker and the
Wisconsin Republican party at the time
were also loudly bragging and boasting
about this and it is because it has
become absolutely uh uh uh it's become
Pennies on the dollar what it was
supposed to be riding on
our tax money an important detail
I spend a lot of time every day looking
at a computer screen and peer-reviewed
Studies have shown that blue light from
screens can lead to eye strain blurred
vision headaches dry watery eyes that
will not be a problem for you once you
get blue blocks glasses which filter out
blue light to help your eyes they are
one of our sponsors today blue blocks
glasses are developed and built in
actual Optics Labs they've been
extensively tested for Effectiveness
there are over 40 different styles to
choose from these are my blue blocks
glasses I like the look I've noticed a
huge difference where I'm not getting
that eye strain or the headaches from
the computer screen because of the blue
blocks glasses they really have
something for everyone a prescription
version non-prescription reading glasses
and blue blocks is giving you 20 off
when you go to blueblocks.com Pacman and
use the code Pacman the link is right
underneath this video and you will get
free shipping on orders over a hundred
and fifteen dollars